[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 28th of
September I'm James Heal The Spectators
political correspondent and your host
for this week's episode
coming up on the show
should Britain leave the European
commension on human rights former
Supreme Court Justice Jonathan sumption
lays out the case in this week's
magazine and he'll join the show with
one-time attorney general Dominic grieve
who's the favorite to succeed Rishi
sunak it's to reconference next week and
the Manchester Jamboree could be a
pageant of aspirant hopefuls can machine
keep a little and ambitious MPS are we
speaking to Katie bulls and Ian Dale
American Senator Lindsey Graham says
Ukraine should hold elections but who
would stand against President zelenski
Owen Matthews will be on the show
and finally the first authorized
biography of Ian Fleming since 1966 is
being released next month so reading
this week's spectator and the book's
author Nicholas Shakespeare will join me
to talk about the man who imagined James
Bond
before we get going if you like
expectations TV do subscribe to our
YouTube channel thousands are joining
our Channel every week and you should be
one of them just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss
another episode
first up former Supreme Court Justice
Jonathan sanction writes this week's
cover piece about the case for leaving
the European convention on human rights
the convention he says has become
intrusive and banal to expand on his
argument Jonathan joins me now alongside
the former Attorney General Dominic
Reeve
um this week Jonathan you write the
cover piece which is about the case for
the UK actually leaving the European
convention on human rights yes can you
explain your argument for us
I've got no problem at all about the
text of the convention
I do have quite a serious problem
about the way in which the text has been
treated by the European Accord of human
rights in strasbour
since the 1970s they have operated in
accordance with what they call a living
instrument Doctrine
and that essentially has been treated as
a way of expanding on the text by a
process of extrapolation and analogy so
as to produce a very large number of
Rights some of which are Loosely
ancillary to existing rights but many of
which are freestanding
I think that this is an essentially
legislative process and involves a
usurpation of the function of democratic
legislatures
we do not need the Human Rights
Convention in order to protect human
rights but I certainly wouldn't like to
see it abolished a less we replace it
with something equivalent so what I
would suggest is that we should replace
it with something that would look very
much the same as the convention but
which would not be subject to the
jurisdiction of the Strasbourg Court
what do you make a Jonathan there
start with something we agree on
certainly uh in agreement with him that
if the United Kingdom were to withdraw
from the European convention on human
rights uh but continue for example to
operate in the human rights act as its
billowed domestic Bill of Rights
uh then I think our human rights in this
country would continue to be pretty well
protected there is a risk that in
certain circumstances on the Declaration
of incompatibility Parliament and
government might decide to do nothing
about it but Jonathan has a perfectly
good point that that can be argued to be
within uh the way a democracy operates
if it's fully debated in Parliament
but that for me is not why we signed up
to the European convention on human
rights in the first place we signed up
to it because it was an international
treaty that was intended to confer
International benefits on the United
Kingdom raising the standards of human
rights in other European countries which
in my view it has done exceptionally
well
and at the same time showing that we
were prepared to be bound by this
International Convention which is
ultimately interpreted by an
international tribunal the court of
human rights as a way of persuading
those other countries to adhere to it
and the difficulty is that if you decide
to leave it
you are going to have a whole series of
consequences that will flow from it and
can be listed quite easily some of them
one of the early ones is that our
trading cooperation agreement with the
EU will undoubtedly be jeopardized it
may be possible to work around it our
participation in the Horizon Project
would become impossible because it
requires data sharing and data sharing
is seen as being absolutely underpinned
uh posts are leaving the EU by shared
adherence to the convention
um and in the context of Northern
Ireland there would be some significant
issues about when over Ireland remained
within the Ambit of the convention or
not and how you would do that if a
sovereign state withdraws because it is
explicit and implicit in the Good Friday
Belfast agreement that we would be there
so there would be very significant
consequences and like everything else in
an international treaty you should if
you're considering withdrawing it or
participating it you should be weighing
the pros and the cons and where I think
I disagree with Johnson is that when it
comes to looking at the downsides of
this then whilst I accept that the court
has occasionally made decisions which I
disagree with and I actually think have
been rather foolish at times but then
even our own Supreme Court has
occasionally done decisions which I
thought were rather foolish domestically
um but when you actually look at the way
this court is now operating particularly
since Ken Clark and I
negotiated the Brighton declaration in
2012 and changed the way it operated in
practice we've had very little
difficulty adhering to it and actually
the number of cases
which have caused the Ripple sins have
been almost non-existent I think last
year the best I would try to look it up
before I came here but as far as I could
see there were only two judgments
against the UK that could be regarded as
covering new ground as opposed to cases
where we hadn't dealt with a previous
judgment until another judgment came
along and they were both matters where
actually the government was perfectly
happy one was bereavement support grants
and uh discrimination and the other one
was about journalists being harassed by
the police for tweets at that the
journalist considered was acceptable and
the police didn't and are wrongful
arrest which followed
um most of the big issues prisoner
voting whole life tariffs have all been
resolved without anybody really being
aware it's happened so whilst I accept
that this course isn't perfect no Human
Institution is perfect I think that the
reputational consequences to the United
Kingdom of leaving and the Practical
consequences of leaving vastly outweigh
any possible advantage that it might
confer us what do you think about that
well I fundamentally disagree with much
of that
um
most International multilateral treaties
are designed to enable one to achieve
things internationally which we could
not achieve on our own
um
this is a rather special case because
the Human Rights Convention is a treaty
which deals with matters every single
one of which we could deal with on our
own now what dominic says is well it
encourages human rights in other places
and that was certainly the rather
patronizing basis on which we acceded to
it originally
we basically said to ourselves that we
already have all of the these benefits
they've been part of English law for a
long time which was mainly but not
entirely true we are joining this
because we want to confer the advantages
that we've had for a long time on these
benited Europeans
um that was essentially the attitude I
am skeptical about how much we have
actually achieved internationally
uh there are countries which have been
released from Decades of turime in
Eastern Europe which who have been
desperate to improve their human rights
record
and have successfully done it I believe
that they would have done it whether the
United Kingdom was party to this treaty
or not there are other countries like
Belarus and Russia and to some extent
turkey which have set their face against
giving effective
scope to the Human Rights Convention in
spite of the fact that they were parties
to it and no amount of adverse judgment
has improved their degree of compliance
Russia was expelled from the Council of
Europe and last year menaris has not
been expelled but its human rights
record is absolutely dismal the human
the participation of the United Kingdom
in the convention has made absolutely no
difference to them there are some things
which I would accept first of all I
would accept
that we if we withdrew from the
convention we would not be able to
withdraw from it in respect of Northern
Ireland yes because The Good Friday
agreement specifically requires that we
confer on them not just human rights but
the human rights envisaged in the in the
convention so I think that unless
something could be negotiated with the
Irish government which I regard as most
unlikely we would have to leave Northern
Isle in the convention system
I don't accept that it would create
problems with the EU the EU treaty
requires its members to have
satisfactory arrangements for preserving
human rights doesn't require its members
to adhere to the convention although
they all do
it seems to me therefore that if we had
a system of human rights which was
dependent on enforcement by independent
judges who are perfectly up to the job
which that would be the case in this
country I think the EU would probably
accept that the problem really is that
we have to decide not whether we like
this or that or the other decision that
the Strasbourg Court makes we people
will no doubt different that the real
question is how do you make law for a
democracy and the problem that the
strasba court raises is that whereas if
you have a whole only domestic system of
Human Rights protection if something
goes is wrong if courts make cine
decisions which they sometimes do I
quite agree with Dominic about that
you can deal with it you can correct it
because you are basically a masters of
your National scheme yourself
but there is absolutely no way of
correcting the errors of the Strasbourg
Court the members of the Council of
Europe have no input whatever into its
decision-making process that Dominic
excites the Brighton declaration I have
to say that the Brighton declaration has
in my view made very little difference
to the way that they operate I spoke and
near the other day to two members of the
Court who said oh that we look intensely
with great care of the subsidiarity and
all these other things which many of
which are basically reflected right
but you have the test is whether this
can be seen in the decisions and I don't
believe that it can
Well I obviously disagree with that and
just to give a couple of examples
firstly there is a degree of dialogue
between our own National courts and the
Strasbourg Court which can continue even
when a strasbour courts made a decision
that we think may be wrong when examples
of this are around
um and
um the Strasbourg Court Hadas listen to
what our own Supreme Court does so for
example political advertising which I
think was seen as being a restriction on
freedom of expression when it was first
being considered in Strasbourg once the
Supreme Court had explained why we had
such rules on managing political
advertising it stops saying with rules
on hearsay in Criminal Courts You could
argue that actually there was a very
extensive dialogue over prisoner voting
So eventually it was resolved by a
minute change to the prison regulations
and I accept this is not a perfect
system but it is one where there's
undoubtedly dialogue and the dialogue is
all the better when there's trust one of
the problems is when the United Kingdom
starts huffing and puffing and saying
it's about to pull out when if you want
my personal opinion there is no Prospect
whatsoever of it happening under the
present government at all so this is
another sort of pre-party conference
puff I have to say to you every time
that happens it reduces the trust and
the reduction in a trust then leads to
examples like applying rule 39 and
giving an interim order to prevent
deportation to Rwanda which I happened
to think was completely unnecessary
because I at least do have confidence
that if the United Kingdom were
ultimately to have a judgment against it
after it had deported somebody to Rwanda
we'd have brought them back but equally
turning that into some great issue in my
view when it's just a procedural matter
um is to exaggerate the problems and
failing to see the advantages and I do
also fundamentally disagree about the
issue about impact
and does it take two examples
and adherence to the convention is seen
as a benchmark and standard of Human
Rights it even has a positive impact
outside of convention countries Theresa
May's willingness to take the brick bats
from the uh tabloid press over Abu
qatada ultimately led the Jordanian
government changing its own criminal
justice system to prevent the
admissibility of evidence that might
have been obtained under torture which
is something I think we would all think
was a good thing and at the moment in
Azerbaijan in the gonna parabakh you
have a humanitarian crisis brought on by
the fact that the inhabitants who are
legally in Azerbaijan whatever has been
happening there previously are in great
fear of persecution in their lives the
azeri government all its faults is a
signatory member of the convention and
will be placed under very considerable
pressure as to how it operates in
respect of a minority Community all
those things in in my view are
advantageous and I happen to think that
Jonathan is underestimating this bit of
UK soft power at best we've been seen as
leaders in this and it has particularly
in communist the ex-communist countries
after the war came down which often had
no traditions of democratic
accountability at all and a lot of
authoritarian administrative decision
making it's made a very great impact and
finally I disagree because Jonathan
characterized International treaties
as being there to regulate relations
between states no I didn't do that so
that's roughly but what I what I I since
the second world war a loss of
international treaties is about the
behavior of States towards their own
citizens and the willingness of states
to circumscribe their sovereignty in
order to achieve certain standards and
obviously a question arises
but on the question of democracy
is that acceptable or not but I think in
the overall context of democratic
government and trying to achieve both
democracy and freedom and the rule of
law I think it's a balance that we've
probably got just about right I'm not
saying that there aren't frictions and
I'm not saying that the court in
Strasbourg always gets it right but I
think that to Simply say you should just
leave this entirely to Sovereign
governments to get on with I think we
will then find that overall the standard
of human rights that we enjoy
particularly on the European continent
will slip
well I think that the all the advantages
which you cite are perfectly capable of
being achieved if we have a reputation
for defending human rights domestically
I don't think that we need the
convention in order to do it I entirely
agree that there is dialogue between our
courts and the courts and the stressberg
court and I also agree that there are
some cases in which the Strasbourg court
has usually without admitting it being
prepared to back down but for every case
like that there are a number of cases in
which
they have not backed down I mean just to
cite two examples
the strasba court has made policing in
countries of the Council of Europe
including ourselves very much more
difficult by considerably restricting
the amount of intelligence that they can
retain or the kind of evidence that they
can use another example the Strasbourg
court has made it extremely difficult
for European armies to participate
effectively in peacekeeping operations
by purporting to extend
the convention to the activities of
armed forces in places like Afghanistan
and Iraq
in the process it has made it extremely
difficult to retain prisoners of War to
the immense dismay not only of countries
with peacekeeping forces in these places
but also of the Red Cross I think that
Dominic is absolutely right to say that
the picture is not is not an even one
there are examples where the system
works satisfactorily but there are too
many examples of cases where it doesn't
work at all satisfactorily for this to
be a sensible way of making law for our
society I think you both agree on the
fact that I think the debater on the
East HR has often been quite the facile
one and then yes and I wouldn't pin it
on immigration which is I think to do
with Human Rights Convention the
problems that we're having due to other
factors and I wouldn't therefore want to
withdraw simply because of EG they
admittedly disgraceful behavior of the
Strasbourg Court over rule 39 and Rwanda
and I got a little pesh time for the
Rwanda scheme I don't think it's going
to work but I think that the way that
the British courts were treated over
that was actually the British government
was treated it was frankly disgraceful
but I don't think I should take single
incidents and treat them as a reason for
withdrawing that that is just rhetoric I
would certain My Views are potentially
based on the experience of Decades of
Strasbourg at jurisprudence
and I regret it I originally felt we
should perhaps wait to see whether they
could reform themselves internally
whether the Brighton declaration would
work I have very reluctantly come to an
inclusion that this is too ungainly an
institution you know with too much
Esprit decor and too much ideological
commitment to change and how do you see
this debate unfolding in the coming
years I mean the conservatives of teen
talking about it had the conversations
normally mentions but uh where do you
see it and when my position is a
minority position both in the country at
large and I think in in Parliament and
indeed even within the conservative
party no I recognize that but the fact
that I'm in a minority isn't going to
stop me from pointing out the costs that
we have to pay
Tony do you think it's going to be a
stable part of British life waterbates
from the echo there's a debate a rally
ECHL has been running a long time
admittedly it's principally been focused
on getting rid of the Human Rights Act
having a Bill of Rights and somehow
staying compliant with the echr even if
though there's a desire to make it
non-compliant and and that has been a
15-year utterly sterile argument led to
the sacking of at least one attorney
general I can think of uh and uh the uh
and at the end of it we have made
absolutely no progress because it was a
very poorly thought out scheme no
I accept actually that logically leaving
the echr entirely has a more logical
um ring to it but it also brings with it
these consequences and it's obviously an
area where Jonathan and I whilst we
agree on some things also I think have a
sort of fundamentally different take on
the advantages of internationalism I was
attorney general when the court of Human
Rights started creating difficulties
over detaining Battlefield combatants in
Afghanistan and I entirely agree with
him I think they had got the wrong end
of the stick very badly but actually
some subsequent jurisprudence suggests
that we've got out of that and they've
now understood that in fact
International humanitarian law has got
to be taken into account the law of the
battlefield
so
whilst I accept that there are hiccups
irritations things I disagree with and
like any International court with 46
judges on it there are going to be
issues around that
um actually I don't think it is doing us
anything like as much harm as Jonathan
thinks and I think it is a vehicle for
continuing to do good and for that
reason I think that this argument uh
will not go anywhere because I don't
think a UK prime minister whether it's
Rishi sunak or turns out to be care
starmer after the next election is going
to be minded to start tinkering with our
adherence to a treaty which and here I
disagree with Jonathan is seen as really
fundamentally important by our EU
Partners in terms of our continuing
relationship now we're out of the EU so
the political consequences of that being
so profound and with it The Economic
Consequences that might go with it I
don't think it'll happen we look forward
to covering that debate in The Spectator
thank you Jonathan thank you Dominic
next Tory conference starts this weekend
and is looking to set out his stall out
of a general election next year but
could the Manchester meeting be
overshadowed by posturing from future
leadership hopefuls Katie balls joins me
lbc's Ian Dale
has been in America giving a big speech
at the American Enterprise Institute
which she noticeably criticized
multiculturalism and the Asylum system
we have Ian what was your reaction to
that speech well I had The Misfortune of
watching the whole thing live which I I
might not normally do but have been
fairly heavily briefed in advance and I
thought well I need to watch it before I
can really comment on it and I thought
she raised one or two pertinent issues
but she did it in a way that I thought
was just deliberately antagonizing
everybody and there wasn't an ounce of
empathy or compassion in the speech it
was all about dividing lines and it
wasn't the kind of speech that I think a
British owned secretary should make on
American soil I'm obviously shouldn't
even make it here I don't know
um but I I thought it was largely
vaguely offensive and she seems to
specialize in this and I don't under
well I do understand why because it is
uh looking ahead to a future Tory
leadership contest in which she can be
the candidate of the right and to be
fair to her if that's a strategy it's
working quite well because everybody's
talking about it but um if she was to be
the leader of the opposition if labor in
the next election I mean I drew to think
what will happen to the unity of the
Tory party I'm Kitty I mean how much of
this should be seen as positioning ahead
of the conference which starts this
Sunday in Manchester
but I think there's a few factors the
number 10 line is effectively she is the
Home Secretary she is giving a speech on
immigration on migration on small boats
and that is in her brief and also the
speech was cleared by number 10.
um but as Ian alludes to I think that
what would probably be a theme also at
the Tory party conference is I think if
you think back to a year ago uh when Liz
truss was at conference
do not want to think back to it if you
say the words conference to MP you know
sellers do you get a bit of a shudder
um
there's a mix
um but I think just how bad that
conference was for the party in the end
um you know it started with Liz trust
thinking she can just move things after
the mini budget instead it began really
with Michael Grove turning on her on
live TV she quickly used hand on a
policy then you had the cabinet losing
all sense of collective responsibility
and she's slightly cool things back with
her speech better anti-growth Coalition
but was gone less than a month later so
it wasn't you know a peak for uh Tory's
success stories
enters a much more stable environment I
think we can still have some
drama some high stakes some blue and
blue at this conference but no
incredible I know is talking about even
those who don't particularly rate Rishi
sunak is seriously talking about the
idea he's going to move before the next
election and instead I think that what
we might have given the polls are where
they are which depending on which poster
you read the most is between a 15-point
lead for labor or a 25 point lead as you
think is an inevitable we're going to
have some succession talk which is if
the Tories lose the election nothing
drastic changes between now and next
year who is the most like leader of the
opposition now already as Ian has
outlines to Ada Bravo Minister somebody
who's positioning herself but we're
going to have lots of fringes and in
conversations I was looking at the guide
earlier Kevin bednock obviously what I
think is all over the place yeah she's
yeah all over this though I will plug
The Spectator in conversation which I
think is their only in conversation can
I plug mine conversations with Steve
Barkley
do you think he's a contender no
you're going to see lots of the names
that get thrown about doing these talks
I think the fact that James clavity for
example is doing it in conversation
onward which is very much a domestic
Think Tank and he is the foreign
secretary and you know what is he gonna
have to say is he gonna give his big
views on domestic policy in which case
people will start to say oh maybe maybe
he's getting ready and kiss to death for
James I'm afraid because I did the in
conversation with onward last year with
Ben Wallace Ben who
so and then Miriam Kate's I think is
down to about five events and I think
actually two years two at a brothman
point I think there's an interesting
debate going on with the rights of the
party
um amongst MPS at the moment which is
Sue Ella bravman definitely has her
admirers on the right but there are
quite a few more speaking to MPS some
advisors who say that lots of something
we're Miriam Cates to somehow hold on to
her seat she would probably be in
competition
yeah so you're the first person I've
ever met that has mentioned her name in
the context of the leadership a speaking
tutorial MPS I do think that there is
they think that she is someone who when
you think about her uh her views on
gender some of the things they're in
trans she has seen as quite a good
spokesperson for them now I think the
problem is if you look I think Electro
calculus it gives her the the estimate
that she keeps holding her seat I think
it's below 20 if the polls don't change
um but it is someone who I keep actually
hearing I always remember doing covert I
interviewed her
um I can't remember what the interview
was about but she at one point in the
interview we were talking about masks
and there was a big should we wear masks
on the Underground and she said I'm not
going to wear a mask on the Underground
I said but you were you're a leader
you're people take notice of what you
say you're an MP no people deserve to
see my face she said which I thought was
was quite interesting and you're gonna
be there broadcasting with oec who other
than the names mentioned who should we
keep being an eye on which fringes will
be looking at will you be looking at in
particular
well I think I think the entire contest
will be seen through the prism of the
the next leadership contest which it is
a little bit early to do that given but
we don't know when the election is going
to be nobody does no no matter who tips
when they don't know
and the the poll lead that Katie just
referred to I mean it is a big poll lead
for labor but it's very fragile because
it's not it's an anti-conservative poll
lead it's not a labor poll lead I don't
think many of these 20 are actually
really enthusiastic about Labor so
although I think labor
as we sit here now will win
um it's quite possible that events might
dictate otherwise who knows what might
happen over the next year
yeah anything that is the sense of
almost fatalism that Rasheed is trying
to fight back from and you know I think
the common question you keep hearing it
which you know is there anything the
Tories could actually do to turn things
around but I do think we just think back
to uh you know this time last year and
how much things changed from the year
previously it does show you that how
many unexpected events but for Rishi
sunac he will be wanting to make it all
about his pitch and try and stop it from
being what this whole segment's been
about
he would be the next leader of the
opposition that's what I'm talking about
mostly exactly and that's what they want
to stand down on I think the question is
um The Net Zero pivot I think
has obviously there was obviously a very
loud part the Tory party that doesn't
like it but generally the sense I think
is you know
speaking to MPS and ministers at least
they think that's something where she's
saying wants to have a fight about maybe
he is finding that you know energy these
signs that he will really go and fight
against labor and election so are we
going to get more of that in his
confidence for each will there be more
policy announcements has been closely
guarded but if so
um you know is this going to be the
moment where actually he looks a bit
rejuvenated you know I mean do you see
any kind of territory where Richardson
actually be maneuvering on to try and
gain that kind of clear blue water with
labor what do you think at this stage of
parliament uh this stage of the party in
government 13 years what really can you
see any levers he should ought to pull
out of next year's election
it's a very difficult thing for when
you've been in power as a party for so
long and you say well we've got all
these new ideas and here's what they are
and people automatically say yeah but
why have you done them over the last 13
years how can we trust you to do them
over the next four so I think that's a
problem for them the other problem is
that if kirstan has got any sense his
entire election campaign by which I mean
from now on will be be to make people
think am I better off than I was four
years ago or even 13 years ago most
people will say no and although I think
elections in this country are not quite
so much based on the state of the
economies are in America it is the
economy stupid generally I think that
there's much more at stake here and you
can always or you could and I think
probably still can rely on labor to make
the odd strategic mistake I mean why is
Kia stama banging on about Europe he
spent the last three years not banging
on about Europe quite successfully but
he's now made people in the red wall
seats remember that he was the one that
wanted a second referendum and wanted
more integration and I do not understand
the logic of what he's been doing over
the last few weeks whereas I think the
one area where labor is taking some
Delight in is the fact that Liz truss
will be at Tory conference and because
we often see kirstana I think struggle
to think uh you know immediately or in
the moment if I had to respond to a
policy position so on their zero it I
did a very Bland broad tweet about how
one made the country a better place and
then it was quite a few hours later
where we heard the stick with the 2030
car Target and but the one thing they
were really happy to attack on Muslims
trust so I think the fact she is going
to be there on the Monday speaking at a
rally on growth and that's going to be
what they keep trying to focus on and I
think label tried to make as much hay as
they can from this idea that Liz truss
is saying things that Rishi sunak then
does do anything to be very effective I
suppose just working within Westminster
I think the number 10 paid quite little
attention to what this trust says but
that's not really the Judgment as well
as voters by it and I think the jury's
out on that do you think there is a
collective feeling of guilt among
conservative party members for having
voted Liz truss in and if there were a
leadership contest they might look at
Sewell abroadman as the new leaders
trust and the local thing we did that
last time didn't work out very well I'm
not sure I'm interested what you think
of that I mean I haven't
you've got a sense of remorse
I do get a sense of actually frustration
that they now have a leader
who they didn't vote for and actually
they you know actively rejected I I
speak at the auditory party event and I
can't find anybody that voted for let's
trust now and it is interesting that the
the fee and I I just put this down to
they don't want to talk about it but
they know what they did one thing one
Theory I had put between my one
conservative MP was that last year um at
the Tory conference the activists who
are most likely to turn out and be at
that conference with the wanted vote for
Richie sunac whereas a lot of people who
perhaps were less acting associations
have voted for this trust so suddenly he
tore MPS who maybe as an association
have been told you know everyone's ready
for this trust suddenly had the
activists who were then most likely out
of the doorstep and facing the anger
from people who you know voted for
sunach and wouldn't believe that what
was going on so I had that put forward
to me I also worth looking at Tim Bale's
research but and He suggests that
effectively the the worst of the
defeaters for the conservatives next
time actually the more likely going to
have those people in seats who voted MPS
and seats who voted for Rishi sunak so
the idea being you could actually have a
two-stage
contest whereby you have the sooner Kite
Party in Parliament and then trustite
membership as a whole and of course how
do you lead a party where the MPS don't
want you but the membership darts and
that could be an interesting question
I'd show the Parliamentary selection a
few weeks ago and it's very interesting
it was quite an elderly association with
about 120 people there and the four
finalists came on the stage did their
pictures they were quite impressive in
their own way
but the most right-wing one got it that
traditionally was the rule yeah I also
think I mean I remember James to be both
attended the 1922 Centenary dinner and I
was their next to a member who was
furious at the party had asda's trust so
I think there's a there's a real mix of
views there and they thought you know
there was a conspiracy and I think uh
conference would be interesting for
seeing you know where the Grassroots are
in terms of where they flock to who
deciding to get behind who has the
largest key but your point James
um it really does I think depend on the
scale of defeat as to what you end up
with one man one name we haven't
mentioned is Penny mordant it's going to
be very interesting to see what she does
at the conference how many fringes she's
speaking I mean I haven't heard of any
so far but
um and how much they put her out on the
media she is also a real darling among
certain sections of the party I I went
to an event last year she was at and she
got cheered and wooped and wrote real
um sense in certain parts of the party
which others wouldn't have had and of
course it will she can hold on to a seat
as a question short majority of 16 000
and Frank Lunt suggested anything on the
15 000 might be up in the air well she
was a guest at one of my Deborah Fringe
shows I did 18 shows and she sold the
most tickets and you think that Tory in
Scotland
selling tickets like that actually
Nicholas sturgeon just beat her but we
all know the reason reasons for that
um but I thought that was quite an
indication she she has an appeal outside
the Tory party and sometimes the toy
party needs to remember that they do
actually win an election you don't just
need conservatives voting for you you
need to have a much wider electoral
Coalition quiet thank you Ian thank you
Katie
Alan Bonnet writes in this week's
magazine about the possibility of a
Ukrainian election who would dare stand
against President zelenski Owen Matthews
joins me now Owen as philana writes in
this week's magazine about the
possibility of Ukraine hosting elections
she says there's no serious opposition
to zelenski do you agree
uh I think that's probably true
um his ratings are still extraordinarily
High
um I think the issue as Sultana
brilliantly sets out in her piece this
week
um is
um not so much the who will win but the
sort of General Democratic legitimacy of
the regime going forward and uh there's
a clear Paradox here
um that uh zielinski has uh he
originally came to power in 2019 uh with
73 of the vote he won by Landslide then
his popularity ratings fell to under 30
percent
um on the eve of the war and now
um he's done such an amazing impressive
job as a wartime leader they're back up
to 80. but uh that's obviously not a
situation that can continue indefinitely
and you have a fundamental uh tension
between the
um uh the the popularity of the
president and the uh executive powers
that he's had to assume during wartime
and the potential conflict between that
and those executive powers and the
actual future of uh Democratic Ukraine
uh you mentioned that word there
legitimacy
um obviously you know one element to all
this of course is the legitimacy
president zelenski enjoys in the eyes of
his own people but there's also an
international element tool that's
particularly given all the aid that's
going to Ukraine uh Lindsey Graham who's
been broadly Pro Ukraine on this has
suggested the view that there should be
elections in Ukraine how much is this
shared by others in Washington and will
there be pressure from allies of Ukraine
for those elections to be held sometime
soon
uh well yes indeed I mean it's not just
Lindsay Lindsey Graham I mean he was uh
he was in
um Kia Senator Graham was in is in Kiev
with uh Elizabeth Warren uh there's
you're being calls basically from across
the political Spectrum um Tucker Carlson
and notorious ex Fox News host has also
criticized zelenski for not wanting to
uh to hold elections
um and also the head of the
Parliamentary assembly of the Council of
Europe I mean there have been sort of
various calls from your Ukraine's allies
uh both in Europe and the and and the US
to uh to hold elections
um the uh I I think it's not an
incredibly urgent problem because we're
not talking about this year but next
year but nonetheless
um I think this is going to feed into
another issue and that is
um that Ukraine is concerned uh and
rightly so for the
um uh that the huge support that it's
enjoyed from the West uh will Wayne
and uh elections are going to be an
element of that mix and the discussion
about Ukraine as we go forward into some
more and more painful period for Ukraine
of growing skepticism in Europe as what
we're already seeing
um uh and in America over continuing to
arm Kiev and so these two things are
linked it's Western support and
elections all become part of the same
discussion
and who if anyone would want to stand
against President zielinski
well interestingly I mean one of the
um well uh the there's the former prime
minister
umoshenko says if we hold elections uh
we will lose the war but that's because
she will also lose the elections uh one
of the um one of the uh people has been
um mentioned is a very prominent General
value it is illusionate who's actually
been uh um an enormous hero of the war
and is very popular among ukrainians
um he has been he's been mentioned as a
possible successor to zelensky uh not
necessarily as an opponent to zelenski
actually
um uh but as a as a successor should
zelenski himself wish to stand down
rather than as satellana points out in
the in the magazine this week rather
than risk a Churchill style defeat as
Winston Churchill was of course voted
out of power in 1945 having LED Britain
through World War II
um all of this is is pure speculation
right now because right now we're very
far from an electoral season as you it
in Ukraine and presumably of course
that's going to be completely cloudy by
the questions about the war and it's
difficult to kind of see any sort of
Democratic or political debate that
really moves much beyond that but has
how much has there been in Ukraine in
terms of looking towards the future
obviously we don't know yet the outcome
of the war in terms of what it's going
to be a kind of you know overwhelming
Ukrainian Victory or a stalemate of some
kind what kind of long-term thinking is
going on Ukraine about what the future
of the country should look like
uh I think that
um I mean I hate to be pessimistic and I
really uh wish I'm wrong but I think
there's actually going to be a very
painful Reckoning uh at a certain point
um about the loss of territories and the
Paradox is that neither zelenski nor any
leader of Ukraine whoever he may he or
she may be can politically survive
agreeing to a land for peace deal
that's completely politically
unsurvivable Ukraine is very likely to
become ungovernable at that point
because of the millions of internally
displaced persons the hundreds of
thousands of military veterans who shed
blood and
um there's you know and and if the
victory is not complete as defined by
zielinski and his team in other words
recovering all the territories including
Crimea and the rebel republics of
donbass should that not happen there's
this gigantic political train wreck in
the offing and a gigantic Reckoning and
I didn't think anyone in Kiev is really
ready to to deal with that and any
uh that's why there's been such a strong
reaction when someone in like a former
presidential advisor Alexia aristovich
said very controversially back in August
if the price of Ukraine's joining the EU
and NATO is the loss of Don bass and
Crimea that's a price worth paying says
Alexei aristovic and that was enormously
explosive and extremely controversial
and so far that none of that discussion
is really in the political mainstream
everyone is now still concentrating on
the full victory in which according to
polls 93 of ukrainians still believe I
mean that's fascinating I mean we
Investments do refer to politicians
rolling the pitch preparing announcement
trying to get a conversation going for
some uh controversial policy proposal
but nothing obviously like what's going
on in Ukraine and I mean from the sound
of it then there can really be no
countenance of the idea or you know
entertaining the idea of anything
approaching a land deal or anything that
isn't pre-2014 borders uh in those
circumstances it seems very difficult
whereby someone like President zielinski
who's been such an iconic figure would
somehow be able to survive in those
conditions um is there any kind of sense
of how Ukraine developed over the next
sort of year or two in terms of having
that conversation or is it really just
carry on until frankly they can't fight
anymore
I think the latter I mean as as I said
um there hasn't really been any serious
mainstream discussion and it's entirely
understandable in fact because the
country is still at War and is still
asking and in fact conscription people
to go fight at the front lines so for
very obvious reasons any any talk of a
compromise with Putin is regarded as
treasonous and also by the way uh
objectively useless because right now
there is actually no circumstance
there's no willingness or realistic
expectation that Putin is ready to do
any kind of deal
um the you know the the the the the the
the process of any kind of uh end game
is still politically very far away and
there's still an awful lot of fighting
to be done so as yet there's actually no
serious discussions and the the
discussions
um will come and um I suspect
um will be extremely painful
um if the Americans are right I mean
we've seen a lot of material being
leaked officially unofficially through
the press and through
um internet leaks from the American
defense establishment that are very
pessimistic about the Ukrainian chances
of a breakthrough
um I'm that's uh I have no personal
opinion but I'm just quoting the uh you
know what we understand the American
military's view to be that Ukraine is
not going to achieve militarily the
goals that it's set politically and
that's going to be a really difficult
conversation but as an an extremely
painful political process but as yet uh
Ukraine is very far from being ready to
have that thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
and finally what was Ian Fleming really
like Nicholas Shakespeare has written
the first authorized biography of
Fleming since 1966 and has been released
next month talk all about James Bond's
Creator Nicholas joins me now
Nicholas thank you for joining us on
spec T to TV uh your new book Ian
Fleming the complete man is reviewed by
Philip hensher in this week's magazine
uh it's the first authorized biography
of Fleming for 50 years or so tell us
how did it come about and why now
well I was asked by the family the Peter
Fleming's two daughters if I would
consider writing a new authorized
biography
um I I'm a novelist and I didn't really
want to spend four years of my life in
the company of somebody who threw
sideways glimpses I perceived as a kind
of a bit of a cat a wife beating sadist
with a sardonic etonian approach to life
I'd written a book previously about
church or coming to power in 1940 and
I'd gone into some of the Fleming
archives about his brother Peter who was
a very much more famous Fleming for many
years a bit like Evelyn Moore's brother
Alec much more famous than the pedestal
first-born child was much more famous
than the the black sheep's Second Son so
I done some research from Peter Fleming
and I think the family had seen what I'd
done about him arriving in Norway in
1904 is one of the first officers in the
second world war to land unoccupied soil
and they asked me if I consider writing
a new authorized biography of Fleming
there had been one authorized biography
in 1966 by John Pearson and since then
30 years have passed and Andrew likes it
then on a very full good biography not
authorized but adapted filled in many
gaps but 30 years on I think the family
felt still a lot of stuff had come out
and
probably since James Bond appears
packley every day in the newspapers it
was probably right for him to be kind of
brought up to date like the films have
been brought up to date maybe bring up
you know a biography that's up to date
with all that that's been found out
since I said okay
um is there anything more to find out
about Fleming I mean surely this is a
Vineyard that's been in tilt to
sterility so I was given kind of two
months to do some due diligence and I
went to interview some of the people who
who'd who very few people left who
remember him I found some of the letters
that they were prepared to give me if I
found a publisher
um it was it although it was authorized
it wasn't commissioned so I had to find
my own publisher and and that's good
because it meant I could maintain um
editorial integrity and everything they
had no say over the final product and
what was what tilted me was you know I
did I want to spend do I want to spend
three or four years the company of a cat
was my kind of question
and what tilted me were two things I
discovered that he was a much Kinder man
than I had hit the two anticipated that
every woman who was in love with him
talked about his kindness and even the
kind of mistress he had during the war
one form called Ward Russell who bought
GoldenEye for him she says seven years
after he dies I think of Ian continually
above all his kindliness now that's not
a quality you associate with James Bond
and it was repeated again and again by a
woman he'd he'd had affairs with they
they kept on loving him I thought that's
really interesting for a biographer the
second
um thing that I discovered that he was
much more important than I'd been
prepared to believe I assumed that he
was a kind of he he'd invented a lot of
stuff in the war that he pretended he
was a bit more glamorous and heroic than
he'd been and he'd cast this into Bond
what I discovered was that he couldn't
write about his raw material because it
was so he was absolutely in the in a
sanctum of British intelligence unlike
Le carre who I'd known for 30 years and
who I also knew they they were very
minor players in British intelligence I
mean Griffin green was in Sierra Leone
and John le Carrie was present to barn
or Hamburg and never had a successful
Mission I don't think and I mean I
talked to him about this Ian Fleming by
contrast he practically ran Naval
intelligence during the war and he was
involved in so many different areas of
the war I mean not only did he set up
this intelligence gathering Commander
unit 30au which went ahead with the
advanced troops and caps of the ciphers
and the Enigma machines that then was
sent back to Bletchley and helped
shorten the wall by 18 months in some
people's estimation he also helped was
one of two or three people who helped
set up the American foreign intelligence
service the OSS which eventually in 1947
became the CIA he's one of only two or
three people in the room setting this up
along the lines of British intelligence
so this has none of this had this was
hinted at but none of it had really come
out I mean when it came out that he was
quite important you it used to come out
in things like a man called
um Creighton who pretended to be the
godson of Desmond Morton Churchill's
great intelligency
Creighton wrote a book in which he
pretended he went back to Berlin with
Fleming kayaked up the river to rescue
Martin Borman and took baumont away and
he writes this as fact and then Duff
Hart Davis who ghost-rated who had also
written Peter Flemingsburg has told me
that he realized things were going wrong
when Creighton told him that as they
were leaving the Berlin bunker they got
Hitler too but then Hitler's head was
blown off by a Russian shell now that's
the problem with Fleming is that you
have people who either say he was just a
kind of deathbound you know chocolate
sailor looking after Astra is all you
have people saying he was kind of
rescuing Hitler from the Berlin bunker
and what three or four years to
negotiate was the zigzag between in
which he was really quite important not
the extent of bringing Hitler out of the
bunker but really with his finger in
lots of different bunkers in British
intelligence what Admiral God for his
boss called The Citadel The
unapproachable Citadel of British
intelligence
and so in trying to distinguish fact
from fiction how much of a challenge was
it in looking at Fleming's wartime
service and Espionage career how much of
that is still classified 70 80 years on
hard to know because if uh sis file
exists on him we don't know and
certainly I wouldn't be allowed to see
it
what is clear is that quite a lot of his
stuff has never been released I mean he
chaired jic meetings he was part of
those who contributed to the Bland award
which was setting up what the future of
British intelligence would look like in
1945 he chaired in August 1945 he's
chairing The Joint intelligence Bureau
to discuss the future of British
intelligence now it's clear that had he
stayed on in 1945 which he was asked to
do he probably would have himself become
headed to British intelligence but he
leaves he wants to go after Jamaica he
wants to join the Sunday Times where
he's being offered the wonderful
possibility of replicating Reuters and
replicating Naval intelligence by
setting up a foreign intelligence
service called the Mercury service which
had 88 foreign correspondents abroad
many of them ex-spooks many of them
Naval intelligence and these were kind
of you know set off to look at what's
happening with communist influence
abroad and he would send many of the sit
wraps as he called it on to British
intelligence so for a few years after
the war he was in a sense running his
own intelligence service under the guise
of being the foreign manager of the
Sunday Times
when that all goes slightly pear-shaped
because there's too much money to do
this and the owner of the Sunday Times
didn't really want to spend too much
money
but I mean kind of escapes marriage back
into his Bachelor existence and what it
seems to me he does is he follows with
Bond the adventures that he might have
done had he Fleming continued to be in
British intelligence in an important
role probably more like M than Bonn and
so many of Bond's Adventures are kind of
the the type of operations Fleming had
himself suggested during the second
world war wasn't allowed to put into
operation often because he was too
valuable a commodity I mean he was one
of only 30 indoctrinated people to ultra
and he really couldn't be risked falling
into enemy hands and so I think when
people say oh he was a card he never had
action they didn't realize he wasn't
allowed to do many of the operations he
himself put forward to do I mean his
famous operation Operation ruthless
where he's going to crash land a heinkel
in the channel and capture a German
speed boat to try and get Enigma keys
from that so that in a sense all the
operations he'd planned in in the second
world war many of whom he sent agents to
do he knew about but when it comes to
the Cold War he sets he puts his
operations in a cold war setting and he
sends James Bond off against the
Russians instead of the Germans and the
other thing that struck me is quite
forcibly is that all you know he's been
held up as a Kind of Wonderful
um precursor of the sexual revolution of
the 60s well if you look at what they
were getting after in the blitz I mean
they were hopping into bed with
everybody every night and I think all
he's doing with his sexual with his
sexual Shenanigans he's transferring the
kind of fetid heat of the blitz into a
cold war setting
our finest Hour indeed
um I was just wondering in the 1940s
obviously got the Korean um you know
spying The Spook game the 1950s he moves
on to writing how does Fleming's writing
change over time uh particularly after
the films come out uh from 1962 onwards
I think it bears
repeating that he only writes the Bond
books in the last 12 years of his life
when essentially his life's over I mean
all the interesting bits his dumb and
he's he's got married to a his pregnant
fiance and rather Amir
who was the had been the wife of the
owner of the daily mail it struck me
only last week that a moral of the
Fleming story is
um date ran off with the wife of the
owner of the daily mail if you don't
wish to Forever After be rendered into
tabloid fat I think one of the the
problems about Fleming is that we we do
see him as his caricature as I got a
wife beating sadist who rules home late
at night from his golf club and goes up
the stairs and smokes lots of cigarettes
while his wife's kind of over educated
friends are sniggering about his latest
book down below that is very much a kind
of Daily Mail reaction to to Fleming I
mean they didn't review his first book
and I think they were quite hostile to
him for totally understandable reasons
for many years afterwards but that image
I think settled in the public mind and
it's been quite difficult to shift
people don't really want to hear that
actually he was quite a nice person who
was a lot more important than we
realized
and so sorry going back to the Bond
books so the Bond books you know he
writes them in two months punctualers
Blossom every January he sits down with
his typewriter that had carried him
through Room 39 and writers and he
clatters them out he doesn't look back
he writes them very quickly like a
Reuters journalist and he he never he
never gets to read them through until he
takes them to New York to show them to
his first editor Claire Blanchard who he
another woman from intelligence who he'd
recruited
um to to Sunday times and what's very
remarkable is he's not kind of at all
affected by his prose I think he's quite
Keen to be considered on a level with
graham green and even more two people he
knew
um but he knew he probably didn't have
the patience or the the the the the the
the
um yes the dedication to write books
that would be like that even though he
admired them and I think the quality of
the Bond books I mean they're very I
re-read them just before I began writing
uh my biography and I mean that
terrifically
energetic and alive and you know at his
best he's like John you know John Bakken
or Eric Ambler or even better
I I think where they fall down is that
sometimes he just doesn't go back and do
a rewrite so we we have the kind of
sometimes just the patch you first draft
in between some some much better stuff
but they're still very readable and I
think as for the quality well I think
because he'd suddenly created this
machine that takes off
again probably people would be surprised
to hear that they don't take off
immediately I mean he's writing his
fifth book From Russia with Love I think
it was when he decides to kill a bond
off because none of them had sold more
than about 8 000 copies
and at the end of it you'll remember the
end information we'd love Rosa Claire
kind of poisons him with a a steel
capped Boot and we don't know if if
Bon's going to come back from the dead
and I think when Fleming goes to Jamaica
that that year he tells his editor I'm
afraid I'm not going to be able to do
another Bond so what changes well the
serious crisis changes
um Anthony Eden has this disastrous
Invasion probably the most important
piece of drama for Britain's post-war
where we do a kind of a D-Day but
without the Americans and it goes wrong
and
Eden
um asked to go to GoldenEye where bonds
had been conceived four years earlier to
recuperate so Eden arrives and the house
becomes one of the most famous houses in
the world for three weeks while eating
is like like a like a kind of bond
villain sending out messages from the
Gazebo to hope the kind of you know to
get the British soldiers out and he
sends telegrams there's no telephone in
there so you have telephones have to be
installed it's a bit like Drax in in
Moonraker in um in in Hebrew Street
um but what happens is that
Eden collapses and his reputation sinks
even as James Bond's reputation Rises I
mean the lovely image Eden is paddling
around the beach at GoldenEye in in
Fleming's rubber dinghy which has a leak
and so Eden's kind of sinking even as
he's paddling around and from the same
Waters James Bond kind of emerges as the
kind of the barn for an Empire that has
been lost to Britain and and it seems
that the the the the the lower the sun
sinks on the Empire that Bond Was Born
Into The Brighter the glow of bond he
becomes a kind of one-man
the one man sue is Force if you like so
what happens is that Lord Beaver Brook
who also has a house in Jamaica decides
to serialize From Russia with Love and
suddenly we go through the sound barrier
from eight to twelve thousand copies to
twenty thousand copies and so Bremen
goes back to Jamaica instead of not
writing another Bond book he writes
doctor no by this time he's created the
machine that is now
Galloping ahead and he has to feed it
every year so from then on until he dies
he has to feed this this kind of monster
he's created and it is in Monster terms
that many of his first biographer John
Pearson
um described you know a Frankenstein
monster he creates that ends up ends up
devouring him and one of the I I I knew
um the war family I did some
documentaries on even in war and many
years ago and what what I remember was
that they kept telling me that the best
sharab Evelyn War ever did was at the
end of the school holidays just after
Fleming had died and evening war was
asked to perform the word bondsman and
so he gets on his black tie at the end
of dinner he gets onto the carpet and he
mimics Ian Fleming kneeling on the
carpet to Anne Fleming his wife and
saying I've got an idea that's going to
make us Millions all this is done
silently and then it ends up with the
creature he creates James Bond throttle
thing Fleming so evening War dies on the
carpet
um rat with a death rattle with his
hands around his throat just to mimic
the fact that he and everybody else who
around Fleming believed that Fleming had
created this the this character who
would end up kind of eating him well
aren't we glad he now persist to this
current day uh Nicholas that was
fantastic thank you very much for
joining us on spectator TV
that's it for this week once again if
you enjoy spectacularly do subscribe to
our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon so you never
miss another episode
[Music]
thank you
foreign